that's a 29 year old Keanu Reeves on set
of speed in 1993 and avoiding answering
a tease questions about where his career
was going it's something that now 54
year old says he didn't really start
thinking about until recently the actor
opens up in the new issue of GQ
admitting he found himself in a movie
Jail after turning down speed to Jason
Patric replaced Keano in the follow-up
while Keanu went to Canada to do
Shakespeare
Keanu notes he didn't work with Fox the
studio behind speed for more than a
decade after he turned it down the
sequel now Keanu says as far as he knows
he's no longer in movie Jail though he
hasn't done a big-budget studio movie
since the 2013 a flop 47 Ronin but he
seems totally okay with that admitting
to GQ that he'll keep making John wick
movies as long as there's demand for
them the third installment chapter 3
para bellum is out May 17th and so far
you haven't disappointed
Keanu tells GQ that working with a then
80 year old Anthony Quinn in 1995's a
walk in the clouds keeps everything in
perspective for him quote there's this
idea that like at some point you're
going to be sent and then maybe there
won't be so much working on working it
just struck me that this gentleman this
legend at 80 is still out there selling
it trying to get parts
I love making movies and being a part of
making movies
[Music]
[Applause]